the State Department has just released
and I'm talking about just a couple
hours ago emails found on the laptop
share by uma Abidine and her estranged
husband Anthony Weiner now yesterday on
CNN Don Lemon has a show there was
visibly annoyed that the Abidine Clinton
email scandal just won't end when you
clearly have top-secret information on a
laptop that you cert you have on a
server in the basement of your house and
then you send those top-secret
classified documents to people that
aren't even cleared to see them and then
you for them to your husband who by the
way is in jail been a million time it's
water no no no no no no no right back
we'll be right back when in doubt toss
to a break you learn that in anchor
school 101 tom Fitton is the reason why
Don Lemon lost his mind he's the
president of Judicial Watch and he sued
the State Department in order obtain the
emails and he's the reason 2,800 emails
are in to the public right now Tom I
know this is always a long process
congratulations on getting it how many
have you read what have you found
well I've read about a hundred and forty
of the emails the State Department
servers went down and you know it's a
big team effort at Judicial Watch it's
extraordinary that we have to get
lawyers our lawyers to sue in court our
investigators to look at the documents
after two years we finally get the
records now the FBI found these records
last year as an Henry pointed out we're
only getting them 16 months later and
they show there was classified
information on on a weiners laptop in
the least at least four or five emails
of that there could be others there but
we're having to dig through the records
to find that out you know and the
concern is you're not supposed to take
classified information off of classified
systems and you're certainly not
supposed to take them out of the office
and you're certainly not supposed to
store them on on secure systems like
your husband's laptop and of course
Wiener was involved in all sorts of
things that make his laptop especially a
risky place to store this type of
information and you have to wonder why
it is the FBI and the Justice Department
let Hillary Clinton and Yuma Abidine off
the hook
after you embed the FBI knew there was
classified information late last year
when Comey cleared Hillary Clinton yet
again why it is they let her off the
hook now remember remember that FBI
special agent who was sending these
pro-hillary and anti-trump text last
year well he's the top counter Intel guy
or at least one of them at the FBI and
would have been involved in this
decision making as well so it's all
becoming it's all coming together we now
know that Comey other top officials at
the FBI Loretta Lynch meeting with Bill
Clinton they obviously were protecting
Hillary Clinton and targeting president
Trump and one of the ways they were
protecting Hillary Clinton was refusing
to enforce the laws against the
mishandling mishandling classified
information they left this classified
info yep on the Internet equivalent of a
public park bench so so if you want to
know how somebody might be as president
you might say what was the last job they
had and how do they handle it how did
they handle it using a private server
how do they handle it not tending
truthful about it how do they handle it
putting classified information on that
denying that it did and then having it
turn up and then getting angry when it's
discovered in October before an election
that she said classified her chief of
staff sent classified material back to
her house this is a country secrets in
at least four cases you found four
classified emails already it only to a
couple of hundred got to get through
almost three thousand so it's her
actions that prompted law enforcement to
have to act so you might love Comey hate
Comey he did not want to have to do this
her actions forced him to find this and
then make a decision correct yes I do
and I think you know Donna lemons gonna
be really angry when I say the following
we need the Justice Department to
criminally investigate what went on here
this time in an honest forthright way as
opposed to the Sham investigation that
went on during the Obama administration
that was protecting Hillary Clinton
their preferred candidate for the
presidency you know Jeff Sessions or I
don't know if he's recused himself from
this as well but the Justice Department
if this has not caused the Justice
Department to do a serious independent
and criminal investigation you know then
we're throwing all the laws of against
the
mishandling classified information you
might as well throw all those laws out
right but you could do anything you want
and if you're powerful enough to get
away with it that can't be the standard
and president Trump he's the president
he was elected to make sure this sort of
stuff was stopped and I would suggest he
asked his attorney general someone in
the Justice Department to at least
investigate what went on here right and
by the way people say why does president
Trump keep talking about Hillary Clinton
as an argument could be made there but
if you flip it around Hillary Clinton
never stops talking about this election
and what happened leading up to a
blaming everybody except her own actions
including call me and wanting this
investigation when clearly she has some
problems they have to be looked into hey
you guys are relentless tom Fitton
thanks so much you're welcome
all right Joel Payne has a different
view he's a Democratic strategist and
former director of african-american
advertising for Hillary Clinton's
presidential campaign so are you curious
at all about about what's on now what's
in those emails this is just a nothing
burger Brian I can't believe you guys
have spent 30 million dollars you guys
being Judicial Watch and all these other
conservative activists they've been
going after Hillary Clinton for years
thirty million dollars chasing a ghost
on Hillary Clinton something that
doesn't exist now you've drugged her
former aide into this you've drugged her
family you've put out misleading
information about her family about
cousins and whatnot understand Joe I
could understand how you not want you
don't want to bring it up and I respect
that but could you tell me what's
misleading about our cousin going to
jail about erroneous emails about a jury
finding them guilty
what's misleading about the about the
anti-american newspaper that she used to
co-edit let's go through and name what
everyone at your cousin's aunts and
uncles and whatnot have done over the
last couple years that's that's
ridiculous that's a ridiculous argument
that's the type of equivalency like that
Brody and dismiss generalization that
comes from this erroneous about it well
what's erroneous is that having any link
to Huma Abedin it has no link to her
whatsoever
it's her cousin I've got cousins who do
things that I don't agree with either
does that mean that I'm responsible for
their actions the bottom line is
here you're trying to distract from this
president what he's doing in terms of
distracting from the Russian
investigation this is a very smart ruse
by the way by conservative activists and
Fox News the network to try to you know
treat this is top news story for the
first 15 minutes of your show it's not
you're trying to confuse the American
people you're trying to confuse your
viewers just a story I respect that you
don't like our rundown and I'm sure I
won't like a rundown if you put together
I might not like the order on what you
do it believe it or not we are covering
some of the Russia investigation if you
were to now I will provide copy for your
home use a little bit later coming up in
the block I'll show you
okay there's a see box about 20 minutes
after but just focusing on this the
number one story in America last year in
late October the number one reason that
Hillary Clinton gives that she lost was
the fact that this emails who were found
on her chief of staff's husband's who's
in jail for a reason we will go into
that a different time was found on a
laptop at home so State Department
things at least six of which were
classified material this is a job
interview a year-long job interview
she's favored to win in almost every
poll in almost every battleground state
and then we see the way she acts in the
in the slip shot way in which she's
handling classified information the
number one reason why she claims she
lost and now for the first time those
emails are exposed so this would even
help you Joel go through it and say look
I went through two thousand eight
hundred pages there's nothing here or
you go through it and say wow there is a
lot here so it is newsworthy in almost
anyone's newsroom I don't know what is
not newsworthy about this the sink would
Hillary Clinton claims that the single
greatest reason why she lost yes it's
not newsworthy for you to be chasing a
private citizen who had another private
citizen working for her for something
that's been litigated by the FBI by the
way your last guest doesn't think the
FBI that I think he wants the FBI to be
disassembled I think that's what he
sounded he said that the FBI in some of
the FBI is a tool of the Democratic
Party is that as Brian is that your
opinion on this no FBI is infiltrated by
Clinton Democrats give me a break Joe I
think for one thing
I think your point out you give me a
chance to separate the rank-and-file the
FBI I've had a chance to spend a great
deal of time with and there's about
thirty five thousand in the country to
think that if there's anything metal
thirty five thousand well thank you and
if I did meet him I would share their
names with you but most of those I've
meet there's about thirty five thousand
the country I'd say 99% are doing things
on a regular basis that are
extraordinary not for fame not for
fortune not for a pat on the back I get
it
not for their pensions because they
believe in this country however if
you're trying to find out how an
investigation is progressing what is
behind it what is what is why certain
people are being investigated why others
you have to find out who's doing the
investigating and upon further review
we're finding some disturbing things
that are being unmasked so I do judge
Muller
Jim Comey and Bob Muller who were george
w bush's FBI team yes they they were
coordinating with the clinton campaign
to defeat Donald Trump you like what
James Comey did with Hillary Clinton's
emails of course not I disagree with it
but I didn't think he called if I
disagree with something and ywhere cave
did if I disagree with something Peter
struck did if I disagree with something
that Bruce or working with justice did
am I being might be in critical of an
entire Bureau am i integrated the tire
Justice Department or am I saying I
don't like these actions they seem to
have a political motivation and if I
want to find out where an investigations
going I have to find out who's doing it
to me those a logical questions Joel
that you would be asking too well I'll
do respect I'm I'm more concerned
with our commander in chief and how he
feels about this he spent the last week
before Christmas going into Christmas
holiday tearing apart the career of Andy
McCabe who by the way has spent the last
twenty years fighting terrorists doing
things that your network before is the
care about so yeah that's what your
president believes in so I'm more
worried about what he thinks and not
what you think seven and a half hours
behind closed doors so disturbing was it
the guys rush into retirement that's
newsworthy thanks Joel for joining us I
appreciate it thanks Brian